can you tell me
this story about getting your entire
family to take mdma
oh gosh yeah
um so a couple years ago i'll start i i
took ayahuasca for the first time after
a breakup and it was very impactful the
breakup is what drove me there and what
i took from it was much much more than
that so i continued down this path of
psychedelic therapy uh having never done
any sort of drugs and having been off
alcohol for eight years at that point so
this was like a big deal for me
and after experimenting with ayahuasca
5mu dmt
uh psilocybin and then mdma i found that
mdma was the one that was easiest to
recommend to new newbies and that's
because mdma unlike ayahuasca is
oftentimes going to give you a
historical
view of your life versus ayahuasca you
might see shapes and the elves and dmt
and it's like what the hell
mdma is like a warm blanket being
wrapped around you that gives you the
courage to dive into
your traumas and what you made of them
uh
and oftentimes the things that come up
are the things that you think i dealt
with that i you know that's totally fine
and out of the way so i got a lot of
awesome stuff which would take a long
time to talk about from my experiences
and one by one went to my family and
said i really want you to do this and
what ultimately i think got them to
agree
was
the changes that they saw in me
particularly my dad
was
didn't want to go but a lot of what was
coming for me in these experiences was
wanting more of a connection with him
and it was tough for me even to say to
him that like
i started telling him like a charismatic
person like you know this would be good
for you and i think it would be good for
your life and you know you would enjoy
this and what ultimately i think moved
him was the authentic truth which is
i need you to do this so i can feel
close to you and that that was like very
[ __ ] hard for me to say with the
quaver in my voice near tears and i
think that was what ultimately got him
to do it in any event last august we all
did it um
together and it was
[ __ ] wild man it's it was wild
talk me through the morning of waking up
and when you look at your calendar for
the day
you have
take mdma with my entire family like
what what does that feel like
so we were we were in big bear um and we
got a little cabin with a therapist to
to help coach us through the experience
i was so
nervous man i barely needed to take mdma
i was on the verge i was shaking and on
the vert like i was i was ready to crack
already um so within minutes of taking
it i was like
you know crying and talking about stuff
and no what i felt was um i'm the oldest
son and what i felt was
terror at the failings of my younger
siblings because i was in the position
of having to have you know of k not of
caretaker but of like i should have
known better
and
terror at you know telling my parents
the disappointments and that i that i
had with them because they were to me
were in the position of that so i was
scared on both sides mostly scared of of
of getting it from my younger brother
and sister for the letdowns that that
i've had over the years
but yeah it was it was a scary
exhilarating experience and
it was one that i was
there's a lot that i could say about it
but i think what the good that came of
it
briefly is that i
assumed
the correct role in the family of oldest
sibling and i think what i had done
was assume a triangulated role in
between my mom and my dad as like
referee of their interactions i was like
a third parent judgmental of the brother
and sister separate from them uh and
what i expressed to everybody is like i
want to be
a brother and a son
not a
guru which is what i am yeah which is
what i am on youtube you know everybody
listens to me and that's kind of the
dynamic that has been set up in the
family like i don't want this i did this
as a coping mechanism for what was
happening like that i needed to to take
this place and so i want to
learn from the wisdom of my mom and dad
and
not have a separate power differential
between my brother and my sister and and
fit in that so
there was a lot that happened but it was
it was awesome and i got a lot of what i
needed and honest to god afterward i
felt like
a life's purpose was lifted off my
shoulders i was like i [ __ ] did it if
i just died today
i did what i had to do um
and so it was it was awesome and it was
a culmination of a lot of different
things and i highly
recommend exploring the idea of
psychedelic therapy i don't i don't
recommend it for everyone and it's not
there's definite contraindicators but it
has been
the most powerful
thing
of the last five to ten years and the
only thing comparable to it is the
realization that i could uh consciously
change myself and now i'm getting to the
realization that my unconscious is most
of me so so that's what i kind of have
to address is not all the things that i
think about but the things that just are
the case about me
man that's so beautiful i'm really
really happy to hear
the progress that you made for you and
your family it's like really gorgeous
and
puts into perspective the work that can
be done
you know there's this strange situation
that occurs
may have been early for you it sounds
like it might have been a little bit
early for you but there's a strange
situation that everybody goes through at
some point
when they stop being
the one
who is
not at the mercy of their parents but
with their parents being the wisdom
givers
and that power dynamic flips and it's
now the parents that are coming to them
for
help with technology for concerns that
they have around
what's going to happen next for i've
left my job for i want to change my
career for when am i going to retire for
whatever it might be
and that navigating that change of
polarity because it just happens
just one day you're having a
conversation with your parents and you
go yeah
i'm steering
the ship of this interaction
mostly now
yeah and only
five or ten years ago
i was completely
like behest to your whims and i i was
based but just this blob this like
useless blob that that you would give a
lift to
sport practice or whatever
and it's so bizarre that dynamic
changing is so
strange and and odd to to navigate
yeah i mean there's there's so many
reactions that i have to that um
[Music]
generally i think that people
underestimate the it's cliched you know
freud made it so stupidly cliche that we
throw out the influence of early
childhood interactions but uh
in the same way that we all have accents
that we picked up when we were very very
young that no matter what happens in
life we will not use like
we have accents in what love means to us
we have access accents in what power
means to us and you can you could be
told over and over again but you will
speak with that accent when it comes to
love and power and all these other
things so revisiting it one is very
important and then more specifically to
what you said
uh
what for me and i think every family is
different is to recognize and um have
enough faith in my parents that just
because they don't know the
technological stuff that there isn't
still wisdom there and i think very
early on i said
because it was difficult or frustrating
or i was angry i said you don't know
[ __ ]
i'm gonna do it and it served me well
you know my dad wanted me to stay a
consultant i [ __ ] off and started
charisma on command it worked you know
there was there was merit to going you
don't know what the hell you're talking
about but
uh
in going back and saying i threw some
baby out with the bathwater and there is
there is wisdom here and the world at
least for me and my family
the world is not a place that i have to
discover entirely on my own and i have
the trust in you that some of your
wisdom can help guide me through it is
what i needed to recognize because i was
too fiercely my own guru my own
independent thing
i think about think about what we were
talking about earlier on that you have
this period of
making yourself
of becoming and then it kind of swings
across into being and then you realize
that maybe some of the things that
served you when you were 21
now your terrorizers when you're 31 and
okay now i've got rid of these but oh
[ __ ] like what does this leave me as now
you know this this kind of vacillation
kind of like a pirate ship at a
a theme park right that it just swings
backwards and forwards swings backwards
and forwards and what you hope to try
and do is to get it to sit somewhere
close to where plum would be
and a lot of the time it's just working
out when you're veering off course
um so for instance with your parents you
know you you go through this period
you're totally correct you're totally
correct that you could see look
inevitably everyone who is a millennial
or sort of a gen zed at the moment is
teaching their parents about technology
and you can use that as a
crowbar to not only have power over your
parents but also to kind of throw out
all of the other [ __ ] that they tell you
to do it's like you can't even work the
[ __ ] ipad what are you going to teach
and
and
learning that again and re-learning okay
[ __ ] i i thought i was the person that
was in control and i was able to help
and be useful and now i need to
de-program that [ __ ] as well and i need
to now reintegrate the thing that i
learned when i was two which is listen
to parents parents often know best
[Laughter]
it's just it's spirals right ever
tighter and tighter circles as joss
whitechkin calls it
yes i i love that uh
yeah it's it's been
i guess when i think about the the ship
it's almost the question is what pushed
the ship to the other side and in many
cases it was like it was pain it was
like i was listening to you guys and it
hurt and so i went never again
and i think that idea of never again
causes people to overcompensate in so
many areas of their life so like they
get rejected by a girl and they go never
again will i feel that pain and then all
of a sudden they train themselves become
these super players who are never in
relationships and never have to suffer
and
somebody said you know one of the most
powerful things that you can do is be
willing to experience the thing that you
made a vow to never experience and to
say i am
willing to be heartbroken again i'm
willing to have my
mom and dad give me advice that is
heartbreaking again and where that
allows you to come back to
it does allow you get hurt again but it
allows you to land in that middle
instead of just having to stay in this
crazy reactive uh refusal to get hurt by
the way that you got hurt before what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you